Санжари після протестів.
Селище з усіх боків оточене поліцією.
До цього місцеві ще не звикли.
Стільки спецтехніки вони за своє життя не бачили.
Спецпідрозділи МВС прибули охороняти санаторій Нацгвардії "Нові Санжари".
До нього привезли на карантин українців та іноземців,
евакуйованих з китайського Уханю через епідемію коронавірусу.
Але місцеві жителі намагалися заблокувати в'їзд автобусів до селища.
Таку негостинну позицію в Санжарах поділяють не всі,
тож хочуть очистити добре ім’я Санжар ретельним прибиранням.
Місцевий житель Василь Васильович не виключає,
що людей вивів на вулиці страх перед невідомим
та, мабуть, не дуже якісна комунікація влади з населенням.
Мабуть, ми десь недопрацьовуємо в плані,
що якщо роботу якусь виконуємо, то треба ії просто підготувати.
Саме це - головна претензія місцевих до органів влади.
У Санжарах і досі не дуже вірять запевненням чиновників,
що усі евакуйовані здорові, а у санаторії і довкола нього
вжито всіх заходів проти епідемії.
В Санжарах в нас медицини немає, обладнання немає, нічого немає.
Навіщо везти в центр Санжар,
якщо можна повезти і зробити  наметове містечко?
Можна ж?
Холодно же?
Все воно з початку неправильно зроблено, якось треба людей,
на мою думку, було поінформувати.
Цей прем’єр виступає , що все утаємничено  все було...
Тому далі що... В нас санаторій - не цей профіль.
В нас шлунково-кишкові захворювання.
У Ново-Санжарській райраді підкреслюють, що
не проти того, щоб у Санжарах надавали допомогу евакуйованим з Китаю.
Однак депутати були вражені як реакцією людей,
так і відсутністю комунікації урядовців з місцевою владою.
Про зміни в житті маленьких Санжар
райраду офіційно попередили лише за кілька годин до приїзду автобусів.
Людей привезли у заклад,
який був абсолютно не готовий
до прийняття на карантин.
Другий момент - те, що цей заклад
знаходиться на території  селища в межах населеного пункту.
Урядовці, у свою чергу, запевняють суспільство, що
санаторій Нацгвардії в Санжарах абсолютно підготовлений до таких випадків.
Ми розглядали багато різних варіантів.
Медики висували багато критеріїв до подібних закладів:
де вони мають розміщуватися, яким чином має бути
організований побут, яка має бути архітектура всередині будівлі -
це має бути окрема будівля, периметр має бути захищений.
Виїжджали на ці об'єкти медики, фахівці з безпеки.
Чому був обраний саме цей варіант?
Причин дуже багато.
За підсумками 14 днів операції - я переконаний, вона буде успішною -
ми поділимося більшими деталями.
Президент Зеленський припустив, що
бурхливі протести 20 лютого мали спланований політичний характер.
Хоча, судячи з усього, найбільше їх спровокувала
некомпетентна комунікація правоохоронців із сільським населенням.
Приїзд громадян до Санжар на карантин було утаємничено,
і місцеві дізнавалися про все із витоків у ЗМІ,
ще не маючи достатнього досвіду з фейками.
Цей сценарій міг би бути запущений будь-де в Кобеляках, в Закарпатті….
Тому що люди були повідомлені з таємних джерел
витоком інформації, що йде щось страшне.
З одного боку, говорять: не страшне, але показують
кадри, як люди лізуть у масках, у захисних костюмах,
а у людей починається: як це не страшне??
Паніка в Санжарах поки не закінчилася.
За даними райради, батьки в перший день карантину в санаторії
не пустили в школу та садки майже половину дітей.
У цьому немає сенсу, каже міністерка Зоряна Скалецька,
оскільки усі евакуйовані наразі здорові.
Скалецька пообіцяла разом з ними прожити
карантин в цьому санаторії.
Активіст Максим Михайлик переконаний, що
нових протестів у Санжарах наразі не варто очікувати.
Якщо, звичайно, не вийде знов якийсь витік таємної інформації.